maintenant mesdames messieurs on passe
au conseil pourri du docteur imex
d'al-qasim s quels conseils donner quand
on veut tomber dans le coma mais
métal et vous voulez que soient radiées
du conseil de l'ordre qua non mais je
peux pas en tant que médecin vous donner
des conseils pareil et quels conseils de
lecture de prendre du poids s'habiller
en noir
j'allais lui demander quel était son
régime préparait ouais non ben il faut
venger très gras très sucré
quels conseils donner si on veut avoir
les dents jaunes qui a fait de l'iphone
ont une chemise blanche
même quand celle voulu donner si on veut
perdre ses cheveux
car des vannes
pas de shampooing je me pisse dessus
colin quels conseils donner docteur sur
me sentir monde et de la bouche
[Rires]
c'est pas d'en voir embrasser bon filon
de moins
et si on va choper une hépatite c qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire abbas un traité avec
une seringue on retrouve par terre par
exemple d'accord très bien faut surtout
pas acheter seringues propres et radié
ah si on veut faire une crise cardiaque
en faisant l'amour qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire docteur
ça va dépendre du partenaire thierry je
pense que
c'est cool c'est pas bon signe avant
sais pas si je les ai ici c'est que toi
tu as un problème je pense que si vous
le faites à votre âge avec une quinzaine
de jeunes filles à la suite il est
possible que vous arriviez pas la 15e
d'accord merci docteur et quels conseils
donneriez vous si on ne surtout pas
faire jouer une femme
vous continuez
givet lequel ce n'est pas de l'aide se
tient si non pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu